i
[Música]
la nueva primera ministra del reino
unido al strass tuvo su primer cara a
cara con la oposición en el parlamento
británico la conservadora defendió tener
un plan para combatir la crisis
inflacionaria y se espera que lo
entregue este mismo jueves además dijo
que hará todo lo necesario para
encontrar una solución a los problemas
haber llamado protocolo de irlanda del
norte
choque entre la unión europea y rusia-
la presidenta de la comisión úrsula von
der leyen propuso imponer límites a las
importaciones de gas ruso para golpear
los ingresos de moscú por su parte la
diputada amenazó con suspender el
suministro de gas y petróleo si se les
imponen restricciones
el fbi auto documentos fue una
información nuclear y de defensa militar
en la residencia vacacional del ex
presidente de eeuu alan outram en
florida así lo revela el diario the
washington post en un informe que agrega
que dentro de los archivos había varios
que sólo pueden ser consultados por el
jefe de gobierno de la unión americana
actualizamos las noticias en la pantalla
de france 24 gracias por continuar con
nuestra señal yo soy juan pupiales les
tras la nueva primera ministra del reino
unido- enfrentó hoy su primera sesión de
control en la cámara de los comunes un
día después de haber sido designada como
la nueva jefa del ejecutivo británico
tras defendió ante la oposición sus
planes para encontrar una salida
negociada al conflicto comercial entre
la unión europea y el protocolo de
irlanda del norte que permite a este
territorio mantenerse dentro del mercado
común europeo tras la culminación del
preside en 2020 en campaña atrás había
defendido sacar adelante un proyecto de
ley que de manera unilateral rompe con
parte de lo acordado con bruselas
escuchamos que dijo hoy ante el
legislativo
necesitamos resolver el problema del
protocolo de irlanda del norte- mi
preferencia es una solución negociada
pero tiene que ofrecer todas las cosas
que establecidas en el protocolo de
irlanda del norte- lo que no podemos
permitir es que esta situación se desvíe
porque mi prioridad número uno es
proteger la supremacía del acuerdo de
viernes santo deber fácil el trabajo es
que el crimen de otra parte de atrás
también defendió tener un plan para
combatir la crisis inflacionaria que
azota a los hogares británicos y que se
está haciendo sentir sobre todo en los
precios de la energía espera a ella
entregar este mismo jueves esa
estrategia que según dejó ver no
incluiría un aumento de impuestos
yo entiendo que las personas en nuestro
país están luchando con el costo de vida
y con sus facturas de energía y es por
eso que yo como primera ministra tomaré
medidas inmediatas para ayudar a las
personas con el costo de sus facturas de
energía y haré un anuncio a esta cámara
sobre este tema mañana
precisamente el suministro de
hidrocarburos sigue tensando la cuerda
entre rusia y la unión europea el
presidente vladimir putin advirtió que
si accidente le pone límites a los
precios del petróleo y del gas su país
suspendería esas importaciones así lo
afirmó durante el foro económico
oriental que se realiza en la ciudad de
vladivostok
putin agregó que occidente tiene una
fiebre de sanciones para intentar
controlar todo a su antojo pero que esto
no iba a lograr aislar a rusia y que en
cambio estas medidas según él amenazan a
todo el mundo informe de alva santana
entre aplausos el presidente de rusia
vladimir putin inauguró el foro
económico oriental celebrado en el
puerto ruso de vladivostok con un
discurso marcadamente nacionalista en
medio de la creciente presión de
occidente que enfrenta a rusia desde el
inicio de la invasión a ucrania
aunque algunos quieren aislar a rusia
como siempre hemos dicho es imposible
sólo hay que mirar el mapa con guayre
nievas mosna uno de los principales
puntos del foro la energía tras el corte
de suministro de gas de los stream 1 el
31 de agosto por un supuesto
mantenimiento la unión europea ha
sostenido que rusia utiliza la energía
como arma y chantaje algo que el
dirigente ruso ha negado aunque ha
advertido que si se llegara a imponer un
límite sobre el precio del gas rusia
detendrá el suministro
además están las obligaciones
contractuales un contrato de suministro
alguien va a tomar algún tipo de
decisiones políticas que vayan en contra
de los contratos simplemente no
cumpliremos con los contras no
suministraremos nada si va en contra de
nuestros intereses económicos en este
caso no suministraremos gas petróleo
carbón o combustible para calefacción
nada
admite que tom austin ante los
crecientes temores por la tensión en la
central nuclear de zamorilla rusia culpó
a ucrania de crear amenazas para la
seguridad nuclear con sus ataques ya que
supuestamente moscú no ha desplegado
armamento en la central y he visto que
el informe del oiea dice que hay que
retirar el equipo militar de la zona de
la central pero no hay equipo militar en
la estación y otro en chiriquí lejos de
mostrar arrepentimiento útil a mantiene
que la guerra en ucrania ha beneficiado
a rusia ya su soberanía para poder
desarrollarse y hacer frente al orden
occidental en el mundo
horas después de las declaraciones de
putin la presidenta de la comisión
europea a ursula von der leyen propuso
precisamente a los 27 estados miembros a
aplicar límites al suministro de gas
ruso esta idea la planteada por
vanderlei en alemania la semana pasada
busque golpear la economía del kremlin
nuestro objetivo es reducir los costos
del gas y por lo tanto propondremos un
precio tope para el gas ruso online gas
así que aquí el objetivo es que debemos
recortar los ingresos de rusia que putin
utiliza para financiar su atroz guerra
en ucrania y desde belgrado ser el
presidente turco recep tayib erdogán de
gira por los balcanes cargo contra esa
propuesta del bloque comunitario de
imponer límites a las importaciones de
hidrocarburos son rusos perdón ha sido
un mediador entre las potencias
occidentales y moscú jugando un papel
clave en el acuerdo para reanudar las
exportaciones de granos desde ucrania
escuchemos que dijo
y política hay un accidente que sigue
una política basada en la provocación
mientras se haga un esfuerzo por
continuar en esa guerra basada en la
provocación no será posible lograr un
resultado ahí
estamos haciendo esfuerzos para ver si
esta guerra entre ucrania y rusia podría
terminar lo antes posible o no pero
parece que no es probable que termine
pronto
pero estoy llamando a que aquellos que
subestiman a rusia están cometiendo un
error rusia no es un país que deba ser
subestimado
mientras tanto los países bálticos
letonia estonia y lituania llegaron a un
acuerdo que restringirá la entrada de
ciudadanos rusos que viajen a su
territorio desde rusia o belarús aunque
la política todavía debe ser aprobada
por los gobiernos nacionales de esas
tres naciones se espera que sea
implementada a mediados de este mes de
septiembre juan pabló lucumí nos cuenta
más
estonia letonia y lituania acordaron
restringir la entrada a su territorio de
ciudadanos rusos que viajen desde
belarús y rusia esta sería la primera
medida de su tipo en el bloque de los 27
la política general es así los titulares
de visa schengen con una serie de
excepciones me refiero a los ciudadanos
rusos no podrán cruzar la frontera pero
las excepciones por supuesto cubrirán
motivos humanitarios cubrir a los
conductores de camiones motivos
familiares diplomáticos pero se
publicarán respectivamente tan pronto
como los gobiernos lo decidan y habrá
suficiente tiempo de advertencia también
se espera que la prohibición de entrada
esté vigente a mediados de septiembre
luego de que los gobiernos nacionales de
los tres países bálticos la aprueben
formalmente
finlandia que también limita con rusia
no se unirá a esta iniciativa por
motivos legales ya que dicen no saber
aún si es posible aplicar esta medida
para los ciudadanos rusos con visa
schengen emitidas por otros países
europeos
esto se está convirtiendo también en un
tema de seguridad pública este es
también un tema de naturaleza moral y
política y creo que en este punto los
estados bálticos han llegado al acuerdo
y estamos ultimando detalles sobre la
política de restricción después
restrictiva
en una medida para aumentar la presión
sobre el presidente ruso vladimir putin
el 6 de septiembre la unión europea ya
había avanzado en la suspensión del
acuerdo de facilitación de visas para
rusia de 2017 y suspendió el
reconocimiento de los pasaportes rusos
emitidos en partes ocupadas de ucrania
en los últimos días mientras los ojos
del mundo están puestos en la central
nuclear de sap orilla en ucrania los
combates continúan en la región de
jarquín mientras tanto rusia dice que
sus tropas han tomado el control del
asentamiento de codema en la región de
donges que amazon del informe
columnas de humo salen de este edificio
después de ser alcanzado por un misil
como supuesto objetivo de rusia según
las autoridades ucranianas
un misil enemigo alcanzó un edificio
residencial en el centro de jarquín como
el edificio es residencial no podemos
descartar la posibilidad de que haya
otras personas atrapadas bajo los
escombros
esta mujer vive dentro del edificio
donde casi queda atrapada
a la explosión y la sacudida del
edificio fueron fuertes queríamos salir
pero nuestra puerta se atascó sólo
quedaba un hueco pequeño queríamos
abrirla pero la puerta del vecino estaba
arrancada y bloqueaba nuestra puerta ya
no pudimos salir más mientras tanto se
han reanudado los bombardeos cerca de la
central nuclear de zamorilla un día
después de que el organismo
internacional de la energía atómica
pidiera a ambas partes que delimitarán
una zona segura para evitar una
catástrofe en respuesta las autoridades
ucranianas dicen estar considerando
cerrar la planta por completo el club
ians en el este del donbass también
continúan los combates y los bombardeos
los misiles impactan en las casas y los
residentes están cada vez más cansados
hubo una guerra en 2014 y ahora hay una
guerra de nuevo
ucraniano retrocede sus líderes dicen
que la contraofensiva que iniciaron en
agosto sigue en marcha el objetivo es
retomar las zonas controladas por rusia
incluyendo las zonas como crimea que se
anexionaron
ocho años
en noticias de medio oriente del
organismo internacional de la energía
atómica advirtió que cree que irán ha
seguido aumentando su producción de
uranio enriquecido y se acerca a los
niveles de producción de armas atómicas
en su informe de trimestrales hoya
reveló que desde mayo la república
islámica aumentó su uranio enriquecido
al 60% en 12,5 kilogramos hasta un total
de 50 y 56 según expertos irán tiene
ahora la capacidad para dar combustible
al menos a una bomba nuclear el
organismo resalta que no puede verificar
con exactitud el almacenamiento de
uranio por parte de irán dadas las
limitaciones impuestas por este país a
sus inspectores
dentro de los documentos que tenía en su
casa en florida del expresidente de eeuu
donald trump habría uno que describe las
defensas militares y nucleares de un
gobierno extranjero así lo reveló el
diario the washington post según este
medio trump tendría su vivienda
vacacional de mar a lago archivos a los
que sólo el mandatario y altos
funcionarios de la administración pueden
tener acceso más en el siguiente informe
es un descubrimiento que hace temblar a
los gobiernos de todo el mundo el mes
pasado periodistas obtuvieron pruebas de
que se encontraron documentos
clasificados de alto secreto algunos de
ellos relacionados con naciones
extranjeras en la residencia de donald
trump en florida ahora hay más según el
washington post los agentes del fbi que
registraron mar al lago encontraron un
documento que escribía la defensa
militar de un gobierno extranjero
incluyendo su capacidad nuclear el país
no fue nombrado pero el descubrimiento
supera ya las preocupaciones entre los
funcionarios de inteligencia sobre el
material clasificado que fue llevado a
la residencia privada
otros documentos recuperados describen
operaciones estadounidenses tan secretas
que muchos funcionarios de seguridad
nacional no las conocen estos documentos
altamente clasificados se guardan
siempre bajo llave casi siempre en una
instalación de información segura y con
un oficial de control designado pero
estos documentos se guardaron en mar a
lago con un nivel de seguridad
durante 18 meses después de que trump
dejara la casa blanca los investigadores
creen que había más de 300 documentos
clasificados en la propiedad el
expresidente ha negado haber actuado mal
el pasado fin de semana hizo su primera
aparición pública desde la redada del
fbi en su casa de florida calificándola
de parodia
la vergonzosa redada y allanamiento de
mi casa mar al lago fue una parodia de
la justicia que se burló de las leyes
tradiciones y principios de eeuu ante el
mundo entero el mundo entero estaba
mirando y está conmocionado orden ayer
world in the world watch en under sad el
lunes un juez federal concedió la
solicitud de trump de un experto
especial que se encargará de revisar los
documentos incautados en el mar halago
la decisión probablemente retrasará la
investigación del departamento de
justicia sobre los documentos
terminamos con la información deportiva
porque el colombiano rigoberto urán se
impuso en la decimoséptima etapa de la
vuelta de españa una fracción marca por
el retiro del esloveno primoz glitch
quien es la segunda en la clasificación
general y aspiraba a su cuarto título
consecutivo gran culminó a la victoria
en una fuga después de un recorrido de
162 kilómetros con llegada en un puerto
de segunda categoría en extremadura al
oeste del territorio ibérico entre los
favoritos del belga a remojo benévolo
mantuvo el liderato ahora con el español
enrique más como su más inmediato
perseguidor a dos minutos y un segundo
el colombiano miguel ángel lópez del
equipo astaná es el mejor
latinoamericano en la quinta posición de
la clasificación general
así terminamos esta emisión en la
pantalla de france 24 quédense porque la
información continúa aquí también en
france 24 punto com
[Música]